Kesha performs praying at the 60th
annual Grammy Awards on Sunday with the
help of Cyndi Lauper Tamela Kibeho Andra
day bebe Rexha and Julia Michaels
[Music]
we offer you two words time's up
Janelle Monae welcome to the grammy
nominee to the stage with a moving intro
we're honored to stand with you and
welcome you kisum singing with her
famous peers all dressed in white and
holding hands in solidarity Kesha hit
every note
[Music]
and broke down in tears the song is
seemingly about her time working with
dr. Luke
in 2014 Kesha accused her former
producer Lucas dr. Luke got wok of rape
and emotional abuse spanning a decade of
collaboration
he has adamantly denied the allegations
et caught up with Cyndi Lauper on the
red carpet before the show I'm I'm so
proud to stand with her and she opened
up about the message behind the
performance this is a real solidarity
moment it's um it's um it's a x times up
moment we want safe environment in the
workplace we make a 51% of the workforce
we want equality equal pay it's about
time time's up